Britney Spears there appears to be new
drama with her sister Jamie Lynn but
where it's not letting it show because
in fact she's gotten a new look
brown hair don't care
Britney showed off her new hair color on
Instagram saying she was inspired by her
sister Jamie Lynn but here's where it
gets a little weird
the sisters no longer follow each other
on Instagram we think we may know why
Britney was there when her dad allegedly
shook her son Preston her ex Kevin
Federline then filed a police report
against Jamie Jamie Lynn has always been
close to their dad perhaps she's taking
his side in the family drama as for
Britney today seems she may have gone
into hiding around noon she posted this
workout video with the caption on a
much-needed fake hey by myself the song
she posted along with the video is also
a little cryptic yeah that's closer by
Nine Inch Nails which later on features
the lyrics help me get away from myself
[Music]
Olivia spoke to the Jamie mental looks
like k-fed couldn't get away from the
paparazzi I wanted to make sure that the
kids are okay and everything's good a
source claims k-fed has custody of his
and Britney's boys 90 percent of the
time
add that to his four other children so
how's he paying for all these kids
k-fed says he makes three grand a month
DJ's but a source tells us Britney gives
him nearly 40 grand a month in child
support
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]